さあみんなー
twitter の違いはじめは何歳までお年玉もらってましたか
えっとねたぶんね大学卒業するまで科学成虫をもらってた気がしますみんなも親戚の人
に
を兼ねた可能猫一体今日は弾み雪です皆さん
宝くじ買いましたあっ
なぜか買ってない宝くじ当たる確率は非常に低いんですけどもみなさん買わないと走破
たらないですだからず地味なさーんやためどうじゃ
どうせ当たんないのになんだかばっかじゃないよああ買わないとは短ないからだよ
どんなに低い確率でも必ず宝くじを買わないと当たる人たちの中にすら入れないって
言う
僕はあの買ってないみなさんはもうダメでしたら僕は儲かってるので当たる当たらない
ですよを買うことに意味があると思ってもう買わないと当たる可能性がゼロになって
しまうんで俺が何を言いたいんだろうよくわかんないんですけど僕今回高値で買いまし
たそれもすごいことにですね静岡にすげー店があってなみてくださいこれ
静岡駅前のお店なんですけど2015年7億円2010
6でも7億円おかげさまで2年連続1等大当たり
いただいたこれは完全にいただいた2年連続1丁2015年2016年7億円でている
を見てですちゃんとた辛口カットの人が久しぶりなんですよねぇーと2万円分高く使い
ましたねますねまずで当たってねあとでたら通すようなの奥へあどったら方俺よくなっ
ちゃうよとも言っ
動画の奥1等の前後賞が入って5億円との組違い賞が30万いいと鍵盤エンチャント
100万円4と10万円ごと1万円ブロックと3000円ならと300円ねちょっと見
ていきますか
[音楽]
サメ件だっけうさぎ300やっぱ腹で3枚買ったら一枚300円でした
あとこっから腹を開けてゆくこれでも700万円でいいから欲しいん
シュルー
それ全部本当に兄弟切れました何とも言えない気分だ
ん
ダメかぁ靴は今同600円ですどんどん見ていきます
うん
me
サメキャンプ
さあ来い
バッハ違う300
んん
いい感じでもこれで
1,200円分ですねやべぇ
a 元取れねえ位
えっち画ザスパいっ
今回の本番です見ていきます
だめじゃん
パッと税大増税増税3世3世二世57だと3000みたいです
やってんだよっドピュッとエッ当然だキュットっ
[音楽]
3000かはっせめて10万頬杖せめて妻コスよいや何か当たりそうで当たらねーなー
まってこれ待って一発4は3型で会ってるけど3型たちがいます
どうしまーす
長毛次いきます
[音楽]
他所行きますと逃げをに本当に強くねーから家強くでいいからと略していきたい
終わったあああ
w はジャガーらー
3000が1本300円が7本で
5,100円
持った
ee
アスタースターだったさっすたという動画で終わろうと思ったんですけどこんなつまん
ねぇ動画で俺は小原事前下にも工芸が二人いるんですけども見ずに適当のエンツォ
年末ジャンボのこの日となって136組508立初4番エブリィ5年末歳暮宝くじの
あたり今日みたいなつは自分で作って隆盛
[音楽]
ブーブーよ
早速後輩2人に僕がんあたかもな名をかたったように振舞っていますそれではまた
yeah
ああああああ
[音楽]
me
わざわざ
えっ
今ってよくなってそうでしょ136
千鶴いろいろアラー
a
2往復じゃねーよ子えっ
よく言われるそうじゃね結構やばくない
やってるよまずやってる
10ハッチャーやばいよな意味わかんねーよ
クズですよね
パッチュッ程度キーなんだけどねなーんだ言っ
[音楽]
car
beaune
me
あっはぁ
ああああああん
あっはい
新品色ボットンって嫌な今日いつもよりドタバタすごいから引っかかった
まず